ah
a woman
uh ladies
uh women two women they're holding hands
uh friends um
uh
sisters oh business partners oh um
oh oh co-owners of a chocolate shop oh
love love what do women love
george clooney it's a wedding
they're brides they're in love
mom dad i know you don't want to talk
about this but
i do i might get married to a man like
you so clearly want and i might not
because this is not a phase and i need
you to understand that
i'm bisexual there's no such thing as
being bisexual yes there is
i know there is because that's who i am
i'm attracted to both men and women
i've known this about myself for a
really long time and i didn't want to
tell you because i was afraid you were
going to react exactly like you are
what do you want us to say
that you accept me for who i am
wow
okay let's go
i am in shock peralta i can't believe
you released morris richmond we had
evidence great evidence that jake found
exactly which makes it even worse that
he let him go that's not fair i was
trying to help but he tricked me you
blew this case you bungled your
evaluation and
you never retrieved my father's pencil
sure i am happy to get you a new pencil
it won't be the same and now you're
standing here mama's a mouse have you
nothing to say for yourself i can
explain of course he can my boy's got
bunches of expunches hit him jake i'm
not ready to be back
you should suspend me what
look when we arrested richman and he
said he didn't do it i just
i couldn't stop thinking about it i mean
what if he was telling the truth what if
he was innocent and i was putting an
innocent man in jail
this just
feels a lot harder for me to put another
human being in prison after experiencing
it myself
it's really horrible look i wanted to be
back in the field because i wanted to be
the old me but
the truth is i'm not the old me yet
maybe i never will be
anyways i'm gonna go cry in the bathroom
peace out homies
you know what you're lost cause i'm down
trying to help you terry's leaving
wait
my second year on the force i was
working a drug case tracking this drug
dealer for months then suddenly he
disappeared right before memorial day
which i was supposed to take off for a
guy's weekend with some friends but how
we didn't know each other yet
oh
other friends while i was gone the dude
resurfaced and got into a shootout with
another drug dealer two civilians got
shot
meanwhile i was sipping pina coladas in
philly from that day on i vowed to never
take time off during a case
also i don't love philly jake i get it
really sucks
but why didn't you ever tell us i was
embarrassed about the choice i made
people got hurt because of me perps get
away people get hurt that's part of the
job but if you don't give yourself a
break you'll be no use to anyone
because you'll be dead
real talk alert
okay
i get it if i could have your attention
please
i'm being transferred to the public
relations office i'm leaving the
nine-nine effective immediately what the
hell i don't understand what the hell
why are you doing this what the hell i
want to say
it has been a pleasure to have worked
alongside all of you for the past 21 and
a half months
i'm sorry for getting so emotional
pretty consistent tone actually these
have been the
these have been the best
years of my career oh no this is new
and i know that
every one of you
give me everything you had
and i will never forget it go back to
being robot captain
me more
see
dismissed
i'm sorry i'm bad at making babies hey
hey don't say that it's not your fault
and look for all we know i could have
don't say you have bum nerds
i wasn't gonna
but
i think maybe it's just a thing we can't
control that is my least favorite kind
of thing i know i really wanted to start
a family
amy
we are a family you and me
so you know we can keep trying or look
into ivf or adoption or if we want we
can forget about the whole thing but if
we're together i'm happy
no matter what
i don't know what i want to do fine it's
okay too we don't have to have a plan we
make the rules
you know maybe it would help to just not
think about the whole thing for a while
and see where we're at yeah
okay
i love you i love you
[Music]
should we go yes
nope
do you know why i engaged in small talk
with you earlier because small talk is
for strangers and con men and that's
what i am to you now stranger no i
i did it because
i am a con man
i was trying to con you into believing
everything is normal with me when
it is not
kevin and i have separated
oh my god
why
it's been a tough year to be a black man
and a police captain
i'm a human
i've been pushed to the brink
emotionally and physically i went into
survival mode and it seems i have
neglected my personal life
does anyone else know not here
i have successfully hidden it for months
not very well i might add i made small
talk with peralta on five separate
occasions and he never even batted and i
just blathered on about someone named uh
wario yeah he does that but you
[Laughter]
you
noticed that something was off with me
the very first day you returned
that just shows how well you know me
and while i'm not yet ready to talk
about it it's uh nice
feeling like i'm not alone
anymore
moo moo
moo moo
oh
what's going on buddy
oh hey don't move oh i was just step
back keep your hands where i can see him
drop that
hey sarge
we felt really bad about moo moo so we
got you a new one
she's called numu i don't want it oh the
liaison application got you down i
finished that i know there's nothing
sadder than finishing a nice long juicy
application it's like why can't there be
another essay or even a short answer no
one is relating to you right now what's
wrong i got stopped by a cop last night
stop for what stop for walking that
makes zero sense unless
oh crap i see what happened yeah besides
that's terrible that's so messed up oh
geez
i have no idea what's going on he got
stopped for being black his woke scully
you